time for a little trash talk
the united states produces more solid
waste each year than any other nation
and as we make more and more trash we're
running out of places to put it
there are two main types of solid waste
industrial solid waste
and municipal solid waste
industrial solid waste comes from
industries like factories
mines
and farms
municipal waste on the other hand comes
from homes and workplaces like offices
it's basically the stuff you'd put in
your trash can or dumpster
like paper plastic bags cardboard food
waste cans bottles and yard waste
suppose you're on a picnic with your
friends
being an ap environmental science
student and all you brought reusable
utensils
you see an old empty potato chip bag on
the ground you're able to identify it as
a fine specimen of municipal solid waste
you decide to pick it up and put it in
the trash but now that it's in the trash
where will it go
most likely it'll end up in a landfill
just like more than half of the united
states municipal solid waste
to store so much waste landfills have to
be really big
one kind of landfill is an open dump
which is a large field or pit filled
with trash
and let's think about the pros of an
open dump for one thing they're really
big
so they allow a lot of people to get rid
of a lot of waste this is why they're
often used near big cities with large
populations
they're also pretty inexpensive to
maintain and they do a great job at
keeping waste away from people's homes
and workplaces
but if we take a closer look at open
dumps we can see that there are some
potential problems too
first off open dumps can be smelly
which could be unpleasant for the people
who live around them
because open dumps are uncovered and
uncompacted the wildlife and the weather
could spread the waste into the
surrounding environment
the trash in open dumps can emit
dangerous gases and even catch on fire
so we could add gases and fires to our
list of cons because these could be
dangerous to wildlife
another problem happens when it rains
the water seeps into the landfill
and as it goes through it gets
contaminated with toxic materials
like heavy metals from electronics or
waste from discarded prescription drugs
this contaminated water that comes out
of the landfill is called leachate
and when you think about it the word
leachate makes sense
because the root word leech means that
this water absorbs and carries some of
the dissolved waste material with it
and leachate can be dangerous because it
can seep into the soil and contaminate
groundwater that people rely on for
drinking
so this can make the water supply toxic
to humans
another problem with open dumps is that
they require a lot of land which means
they cause habitat destruction
another kind of landfill is a sanitary
landfill
and you may be thinking how could a
landfill a pit of trash be sanitary
well sanitary landfills have something
that open dumps don't a liner which is a
layer of clay or plastic that keeps the
trash in
and every day
when trash is put in a landfill it's
covered by a layer of construction
debris or low quality soil
and then it's compacted into a cell
and the process repeats
with all of its tightly sealed and
compacted cells it's very hard for water
to get into the landfill so sanitary
landfills keep the environment inside
really dry
but over time rainwater will eventually
infiltrate the layers and form leachate
the tightly sealed cells prevent water
from leaving too so leachate can build
up inside the landfill some sanitary
landfills are built with double liners
and pipes so that leachate can be stored
and treated
if you went inside a sanitary landfill
you wouldn't be able to breathe
and not because it would be super smelly
this is because the cells are sealed up
so tightly that it's hard for oxygen to
get in and circulate the environment
inside is mostly anaerobic
which means that there is little oxygen
you see the prefix and means not or
without and the word aerobic means
involving or requiring oxygen so the
word anaerobic describes a place without
oxygen
so aerobic decomposition which is a
process of decay that takes place in
aerobic environments and involves
microorganisms that need oxygen to
survive can't occur
instead anaerobic decomposition
which is decay by microorganisms that
don't need oxygen takes place
this process produces methane a
greenhouse gas that contributes to
global warming
it could take several decades or even
hundreds of years for the tightly
compacted waste in a sanitary landfill
to decompose so this type of landfill
can contribute to global warming for a
long time
so what are the pros and cons of
sanitary landfills
compared with open dumps sanitary
landfills are less smelly and less
likely to catch on fire
and because sanitary landfills keep the
waste inside covered and compacted we
don't have the same problem of the
wildlife and the weather moving around
the waste
but no landfill is perfectly sealed so
leachate can still seep out
adding and compacting layers of trash
causes dust and noise
also remember that the anaerobic
decomposition in sanitary landfills
produces methane a greenhouse gas but
some sanitary landfills capture the
methane emitted by the decomposition so
that it can be burned to generate
electricity this can capture 60 to 90
percent of the methane produced by the
landfill so that methane capture could
be a pro because it generates
electricity
sanitary landfills are really expensive
so they're a lot more common in more
economically developed countries
and like open dumps they require a lot
of land
one way to reduce the amount of material
that needs to be landfilled is by
burning it in an incinerator this
reduction in the volume of the waste is
really helpful in areas with limited
land space so reducing the volume of
trash is one of incineration's pros
modern high-tech waste to energy
incinerators have another pro they can
produce electricity and sell it to
consumers
some of the cons of burning trash are
that it emits co2 ash waste hazardous
gases
and other air pollutants
incinerators could be built to help
reduce these emissions by using a series
of filters to remove mercury and dioxins
from the exhaust gases another way to
lessen the danger of burning trash is by
sorting out the hazardous materials
before the incineration but these safety
features like the filters and the
sorting make waste incineration much
more expensive
despite all these ways of getting rid of
waste we're still having trouble finding
places to put it the landfill near my
home filled up so my county transfers
its waste to a sanitary landfill and a
neighboring state and this
transportation burns fossil fuels and
produces greenhouse gases
but what could we do with the landfills
that are already filled up
some old landfills are mined for
valuable metals and recyclable materials
my home state of virginia turned an old
closed landfill in virginia beach into a
public park called mount trashmore park
it's actually one of the most popular
parks in the area
so if you ever feel like picnicking on a
landfill that might be the one to try